how's it going guys it is june 19th 2022
and for me the 19th is sort of a special
day every month because that is the day
i am forced to update my game engine
which was formerly ancient archer you
know a project i started in college when
i was kind of making my first game for a
class
and it has somewhat evolved into
something bigger but it's more recently
been renamed into just archer engine a
little more symbol of a name and get rid
of the ancient because well now i feel
like the ancient was its original i
don't know what the heck i'm doing state
not that i know what the heck i'm doing
now but you know you gotta you gotta
move forward so i uh just gonna talk
about it and i wanna talk a little bit
about just game development in general
for people who don't want to use a game
engine but would rather prefer to roll
their own so i feel like they're we're
like this niche group and i talk to a
lot of you guys some of you are in the
discord or leave comments
and you know i watch a lot of other
people's videos that are doing the same
thing
and there's a gazillion projects online
on github and stuff
for other people doing the same thing so
it's it's interesting but well i'll get
to that more later but uh first let's
talk about the changes there really
wasn't a whole lot i was trying to get
in uh some major pbr changes but
it's complicated so those didn't really
get fully integrated but i do have a
messy branch that i never committed full
of
just some various pbr stuff that i
ultimately scrapped because it was
becoming chaos and it wasn't working
correctly but uh anyway
so let's talk about what changed for
this 1.4 update
uh let's see here pull requests closed
yeah i just closed one okay so i'll just
go over this real quick because this
this includes everything right here uh
this merge 33 so typically i'll talk
quickly about how i do these branches
the main gets updated specifically on
the 19th when it's time to do the final
merge
before that all the changes that are
happening for the month go into dev but
before they go into dev
a branch is made off of dev and you know
you do whatever and then when that's
kind of ready you merge it into dev so
that should allow multiple people to
work on it but that's one of the things
i want to talk about it's just kind of
an open invitation to to work on this
because i do have some goals and there's
just no way i'm going to meet them on my
own anytime soon so
definitely need some help from the
public at some point
uh if they're willing to you know you
can't force anybody anyway let's talk
about the changes the main thing here
the biggest change uh let's see i did
some minor stuff renamed a few things uh
updated the main uber shader which is
kind of the default shader if you don't
do anything special and it just gives
you that shader
i added some basic materials so uh
previously the only way you could get
materials is if your model file
if if it had
like png textures or some kind of
textures that went with it
[Music]
so now also if it has material files
that are or material specifications that
aren't textures at all but rather just a
diffuse ambient specular emission
and if it just has some of those it will
just automatically use those so if those
are specified in your model or in your
meshes
on your model file
it's going to pick those up and just
kind of automatically display them
so i tried to get uh
i tried to get that working properly and
it seems okay we'll we'll give it a run
later and i'll show you the some of the
differences it's kind of hard to see in
some of the cases but basically it just
takes these all into account now and it
does definitely look a lot better in
some cases where things would just be uh
just like well i had to go into a red
color if it wasn't picking up any
textures just as like a debug color so a
lot of those reds are now fixed in a lot
of modif model files and should display
the actual material that's specified
so now yeah your models can have uh of
course the normal textured stuff
but also now they can have material
specifications so a lot more stuff is
supported still not
uh it still doesn't support a lot of
stuff though so
still not as good as the big game
engines of course but we're getting
there small incremental stuff that was
really the big changes i also wanted to
start adding in some controller support
which i looked at and uh started kind of
hashing out a little bit but didn't
actually get to adding any of that stuff
so the controller support didn't make it
really only the material support
made it and tweaking to some shadows and
stuff so uh yeah i spent
most of the time messing with pbr and
that didn't make it in oh and uh that's
just the way it goes
so i'm gonna go ahead and check out main
here on uh github using fork do a pool
oh apparently i have changes i need to
stash oh okay
i guess another thing i just have a
little game file thing i started messing
with uh i guess i need to stash all that
first
all right we'll do that so i'll stash
all that stash and get is just some
local changes that you're uh putting to
the side basically so
i'm just gonna call this et because that
is the uh working name of the game i'm
making
all right and then i'm gonna do a pool
to get the latest stuff that i just
merged in from the website
and then i'm going to open up the
project here in visual studio 2022
because that's the build system we're
using ideally i'd like to go to cmake
eventually but for now we're going to
stick with visual studio
all right so you can see over here at
the top left i have download test
resources editor engine and unit test i
took the aaa off the front of all these
project names just because it was
redundant at this point it used to stand
for ancient archer but since the project
is no longer
named that now it's just just editor
engine and editor and engine basically
the download test resources are just
some model files and sound files
required to run the unit test and that's
really all they are so you run that
first it's going to download everything
you do have to unzip them and put them
in the folder but i believe all the
directions are in there
this has actually been there but yeah
there it is it says right at the top of
the uh cpp yeah just running this we'll
do all the connection and download the
zip file but uh
yeah that's just a little basic basic
thing uses curl all right the editor
still doesn't do a whole lot it just
gives you a little flying camera
basically and it has drag and drop
supported so you can drag in models you
can't do anything else but it does give
you at least the defaults for loading
models so you can kind of test out
models if you run the editor as the
basic point and then fly around and look
at them but you can't really do a whole
lot else right now the editors it's it's
not actually functional uh but it's a
work in progress and something i'll
tweak later i don't know if i'm actually
gonna make it fully fledged because this
is sort of meant to be uh it's sort of
you're sort of meant to work on things
in a different way uh with this
particular engine but for now basically
you just you just use the engine as a
library and you just use that library to
load up all your media stuff and do
stuff with your loop it's a lot like ray
live if you've ever used rayleigh and
there's some other
similar libraries like that i'm just
trying to keep it super simple so
including the engine gets you like the
audio 3d stuffs basic shaders and uh
you know some basic mouse and keyboard
support and some windowing option
support so it just handles kind of a lot
of stuff all in one
so uh yeah let's give the unit tests a
run because this is where i basically
always run these anytime there's some
major changes and make sure it doesn't
break anything i previously had going
because the unit test essentially just
uses the interface uh which is the
public part of the engine uh you can see
this include here this is all the public
parts so if you're using the library
these are the headers you can mess with
to do stuff
so these are kind of constantly changing
and i'm often making more stuff public
as we go but essentially you just
interface with this interface.h and it
has all the main public functions
to do all the stuff with the program
that you might want to do that's why
these are all worked up with comments
and stuff all right
let's run the unit tests so i'm going to
go up here to tests uh
yeah test explorer and then just hit uh
run all tests as soon as it gives me the
option and i've got 12 current unit
tests some of them are cooler looking
than others but we're going to wait a
minute because this is going to update
any of the libraries required using
vcpkg as the package manager i guess
i'll talk briefly about this uh i sort
of have mixed feelings about vcp pg it
works great it's very nice in that uh
i don't have to really worry about stuff
so that's nice because just you know i'm
doing it locally for this project so uh
we see pkg you can kind of install
libraries globally if you want kind of
like how linux is when you use apt-get
install for libraries and they just work
you can do that or you can have a
manifest file which downloads your
libraries locally
for your project and that's nice for
shipping your project
because you can ship the required
libraries with it you can do so the
global way too but i think it's a little
more complicated
so i just chose to make them local and
it just keeps them updated and
apparently there's been some recent
updates so it's uh updating the
libraries here it doesn't always do this
but it also automatically updates for
debug or release or whatever you have it
set to so that's super nice
i have a whole video on both of those on
the global way of doing it with me pkg
and the local way of doing it with a
manifest so uh
check those out if you're not really
sure how to do it i don't want to do it
again or make the tutorial yet again
but i'll just say basically you need
this json uh bcpg json you can check it
on a kit how to be curious about how
it's supposed to look like it's very
basic and then on any of your projects
that use it you got to go to the
properties and
under this vcpg you got to change the
manifest to yes and that'll use it it
defaults to no so it only actually works
if you make the file and then turn it on
and it does it for well you have the vc
pkg json at your top level your project
and you see all the individual projects
have their own toggle but they use the
top level one so
that's about it
so this thing is still building it's
taking a while and i'm just kind of
using these videos a little bit of an
opportunity to also uh vlog about
updates to my life a bit at this point
because this isn't really like a normal
channel topic you know normally i'm
trying to do like series of tutorials
and this is kind of just an off thing or
it's my personal project i'm making a
game engine to to support a game i'd
like to make but uh in other news i know
i've been saying it for like a month and
i'm moving that i'm moving and uh yeah
it's it's the reality now i'm on the
last week and i will no longer be at
this location after about another week
so you'll never see this background
again and i've been at the new house uh
fixing things up doing a lot of mowing
doing a lot of trimming of the yard and
i keep getting all this poison ivy and
stuff so that's why i got getting all
these weird bumps on me uh it's just a
lot of poison ivy i think irritation
from that
but uh yeah so i've been outside a lot
and been been moving stuff a lot and
it's been very nice it's been refreshing
i don't normally get outside this much
and also that's one of the things that
kind of slowed down the development
recently too it's just uh me preparing
for the move i've just been boxing up
things in the house
shifting around the large furniture
trying to get the bulk of everything
done before the deadline of me having to
be out of here and that way i have time
to clean too
all right you know the big thing i
wanted to talk about is
people rolling their own game engine and
and why we do it i guess and you know
i've seen a
this is a touchy subject in a way
because it's almost painful to uh think
about for me i've seen a lot of people
do this and then give up quite quickly
which is fair it's a massive undertaking
and if you know takes a lot of
stick-to-it-ness and a lot of uh
humility to to do this because you
basically have to accept that you're
never going to be as good as any other
engine out there it's the reality of it
if you go look at any of the more
popular roll your own game engines on on
github for example they
they're all better than archer engine
they all support more stuff they all
sound cooler they all have prettier
demos you know that sort of thing so
looking at those you know it's sort of
an inspiration as to okay this is what i
need to go towards and this is what i
can do but it's also like holy crap man
it's going to take so much work to to
catch up to this guy and that sort of
thing so
in a lot of ways it's it's painful and
you just kind of have to you know maybe
that's why most people quit is they
think i can just use one that's already
better and uh based on that
you got to have some other reason to
keep going i think so i'm curious what
other people think about all this but
i guess for me it's just a learning
experience at this point and just a
source of i want to know how to do this
stuff it's it's both of those really at
this point it's like when i when i dive
in to add a new feature sure i could
just go get someone else's library and
just do it but what i find is often just
figuring out their antics and their
library literally takes me as much time
as just building it myself would take so
that's often why i just go back to my
engine like i'll start doing stuff on an
unreal or still i'll start working
towards something i want to build and i
just get stuck on all these like things
that i feel like should be easy but
they're not
and it's like you already support it why
can't i just
use what you got but their stuff doesn't
seem to work as i would expect
and uh so it's
it's uh
i don't know i almost want to say it's
easier for me to build my build it
myself because then i understand all the
code and how it's working and what's
going on rather than trying to use
somebody's tool and just like if it
works great but i don't understand it
you know there's there's something there
where i just want to i just want to know
i'm just that sort of person i guess
that's why i have this channel it's
because i'm the sort of person who just
dives in and
gives it their best shot even if they
don't really know how to do it
to perfection and i think that's like a
really important thing that you have to
have if you're gonna roll your own game
engine or build anything really because
unless you're like the best programmer
in the world which let's face it nobody
is that there might be one best
programmer in the world who can build
whatever they want at will uh you know
coating it all up from scratch but even
them it's gonna you know it's gonna take
years probably so don't be too hard on
yourself when you get stuck on things
this is really hard and complicated
stuff with so many layers that you have
to understand
to to get there and
yeah i don't know what else to say about
it i'm just kind of going on a rant now
but i'm curious what other people think
of that
so
i guess from there i just i kind of want
to give an open open invitation to work
on this if you want to work on it if you
want to add a feature add a feature if
you want to ask me questions about how
it works and where you should put things
you can ask me
i kind of change things frequently with
this engine and move things around but
it's pretty straightforward for an open
source project you know in the engine
there's an include in the sort and
source all the source stuff is generally
private
and the interface is what generally
accesses and changes it
so
you can see in the basic unit tests how
to set up the basic projects or in the
editor how to generally run basically
you just instantiate the engine call
init and call run doesn't seem super
complicated to me but i've done it a
million times and i also kind of
designed it so it probably seems a lot
more simple to me because of that and
that brings me to uh yeah kind of what i
want to accomplish for the next month
and basically this next month is what
i'm going to call crossbones so version
1.5 which will come out in a month from
this video's release is going to be my
chaos month i don't really have any
plans basically what i'm going to do is
try to make some ground on initializing
the project that i want to make and just
kind of see how far i can get before
things don't work for me anymore and
that should give me an idea of what to
add but also i want to be very open to
public changes during this time so if
people want to add stuff and it doesn't
break my current thing i'm just going to
add it and say okay and kind of go from
there
and i'm probably just going to add stuff
kind of at will for whatever i feel like
i should add
so it's it's going to be i feel like
it's going to be an interesting month
and i'm curious to see what changes will
come about
uh in this next month and if you are too
then uh i don't know maybe hit subscribe
in the bell
so you cannot miss it so i also might
stream this so you're welcome to go to
my stream and follow there to see when i
go live i'm usually playing league of
legends or some game but occasionally
i'm going to program and i might program
some of this just a total chaos just for
the fun of it and see if we can have it
laugh if things breaking um twitch.tv
slash matt early possibly might change
my name again over there to something
probably
[Music]
i'm always going back and forth changing
my name i guess to briefly talk on that
i don't know i'm just not settled on a
public name like sometimes i'm okay with
using my public name but sometimes i'm
like well i don't necessarily want my
real name associated because i you know
i kind of want to be a little crazy and
do some weird stuff and i don't
necessarily want that tied to my name
i'd rather just be some rando on the
internet when i'm doing weird stuff you
know so that's why i go back and forth
to change my name but ultimately i don't
care i'm i'm kind of learning to accept
myself and not be too uh hurt by others
opinions for lack of a better way of
explaining it so
self-acceptance is huge here we go
here's the 1.4 current run state with
the unit test default init
i'll talk briefly on what these actually
do to
you can always click on these and click
on the the code just go right to the
code of where the test is which is super
cool so you can see what it looks like
but hey
defaulting it basically just makes sure
it initializes and runs a little i am
gui interface here fireplace room this
is a room that uses materials that
aren't all textures this is still a
little buggy but this is essentially
something that that should all load
correctly one day but it's getting
better it looks a lot better than i did
in last update you can see
for some reason
these aren't stretched to the edge
properly on the textures on the floor
not sure why but they're supposed to be
i think i need to load some sort of
uv thing different there's apparently
different uv options and i don't have
them all supported properly so that's
another thing i gotta figure out
uh but you can see this is no longer
just a flat red and this is like a
little gray material the walls have a
darker material so the materials are
generally kind of working
but they're not perfect
and i think there's just um
there's a point light in here somewhere
i don't know where it's at but it's kind
of hard to move around if you can get it
somewhere in the room you can see that
it will light it up oh there's a
flashlight too apparently uh i forgot
about that there should be a sun too
okay it's hidden behind here yeah
there's a sunlight too so you can adjust
that too and kind of see the differences
it makes and the scene
so this room it's mainly to test those
new
non-non-picture texture i'm calling them
materials they're just like material
stuff so it kind of works still needs
improvement it doesn't work perfectly
like if you load this same scene in
unreal or unity it looks a lot nicer
than it does here
uh but it's getting better all right so
that's all that this test really is is
just testing that kind of stuff some
lighting tests this is uh i'll make this
full screen this is just a test where i
have some models loaded up
and have the ability to kind of walk
around but mainly we're just testing the
lighting and the shadows
here so uh yeah there's a bunch of
different lights and just kind of make
sure everything looks semi-correct
this guy in particular has materials and
has uh
textures that are pictures so he's got a
common kind of a combination of both
and the rest of these i think are just
all textures this
floor has some material specifications
too and that was something that's hard
to get working right but in general i
just mainly use this to play around with
the shadows oh yeah i still haven't
fixed the uh adding the transforms
before the shadow so that's just
something i actually just kind of forgot
about as i got working but all right
this one here actually just tests that
the models were used properly like
they're using the same graphics card
models basically it makes sure it
doesn't load the same model twice but
rather just reuses stuff that's already
loaded so actually this just auto fails
if that doesn't happen uh so since it's
not crashing it's working fine let's go
to the next test so that'll crash if you
ever mess up the the reuse model
resources this is just an animated model
test i actually need to improve this to
add some more animations and let you
change them
but basically just make sure that this
guy actually uh
animates
uh let's see what says the skybox test
just basically test switching to
different skyboxes doesn't let you move
the camera camera automatically moves in
a little circular swivel fashion
basically you can swap sky boxes out at
will that way if you're making a game or
something you can change your background
or whatever however you want
uh the sound effect test test
loud warning here these just basically
load up a few hogs and waves and just
make sure they actually work i'm gonna
click a few of them uh i guess i'll turn
the volume down first on this recording
because there these are blaringly loud
usually here we go
coin
flashlight gunshot
alert sound
but yeah these all seem to work and you
can click them real fast if you want
that way you can i don't know there we
go yep they work fine a little uh space
scene mashup i just did a bunch of
different things here just kind of
made sure a combination of things worked
this is a weird scene because you know i
got outlines working or stenciling which
is great for selecting stuff and whatnot
and making sure you can see things from
far away or know where they are in the
world and stuff like that uh
they seem okay but i don't know how
actually useful they are that's really
all this is just a mashup of different
stuff this one uh tests some stenciling
you can see these guys are stenciled
with gray one of these cubes is
stenciled these other ones are not so
when you're
behind something that's not stenciled
you can see right through it that way
you can find your stuff and if i go
below the world i guess it's not a great
test
but yeah just some stenciling test looks
fine
sunlight shadows okay i guess this is
just uh some sun shadow stuff i wanted
to test it with things moving like that
cube moves and you can see its shadow
down there should move probably have to
adjust these bias stuff these always
need to change based on how your scene
is so
i think i need to yeah decrease it to
get that one to look good the ortho size
anyway
this plane usually want it high well you
can kind of play around with stuff here
and make sure it works seems okay
windows options oh this is just testing
you can kind of like have min and max
sizes you can set so this is just kind
of testing that seems to work fine and
also the full screen feature uh where
you have you know no top bar and stuff
that should toggle yep seems to be okay
starting size this is a new test
basically i noticed there were some odd
bugs where if you put in a custom
starting size it wouldn't always work so
i just made a test to sort that out so
this uses a custom starting size and it
seems to be fine here so i'm just going
to hit yes that's basically all the
tests so far
uh definitely need some more tests some
of the stuff i mentioned there that
would mention like the animation
animations need
switching and i need more the animations
are still the same as they were a while
ago i i just basically got them working
and then walked away because there was
just a lot of stuff i didn't quite
understand
so that's just another thing is the
animations need improved but don't worry
during chaos month we're going to be
stress testing the animations and
probably making some changes to the code
there because there's definitely some
bugs in it that will uh come up and
there's some there's something about the
way the animations loop i don't think i
have it interpolating
the end of the loop to the beginning of
the loop properly because there's kind
of this snap glitch at the end of every
animation
now little stuff like that that needs
improved uh basically but there's
probably also more because
there isn't exactly good support for
understanding what skeleton should go
with what models and stuff so you can
get some odd things happening if you
haven't fully tested your skeletons
beforehand
all right what else to talk about that's
the main stuff i think i've talked about
basically everything that i can think of
so i'm gonna end this vlog here i think
so if you're still here thanks for
watching i appreciate you guys if you
want to support the project you can just
give it a star on github or something
i'll leave a link down below of course
you're welcome to support me if you want
i have a patreon and there's all kinds
of buttons everywhere here on youtube
you know the like the sub there's also a
join button if you want to get special
cool stuff next to your name and when i
eventually do my luck 10k live stream
you can do it there and stuff too but
until then i'm just going to stream some
on twitch
yeah i can't think of anything else to
say just i appreciate you guys i'm going
to roll the patron thing for helping
keep this channel going i really
appreciate you guys in the financial
support it does mean a lot and uh you
know all the sport does just comments in
general do too all right i'm out peace
guys
[Music]
you